[Music]
[Applause]
Dan Wetzel covers college sports and uh
Yahoo sports columnist podcast host as
well he was at the Michigan and Ohio
State game what was that atmosphere like
in say the latter part of the second
half Dan well I think unfortunately
we've all been to a wake
yeah
funeral uh only without the uh
people trying to say let's have a
celebration of life and like talk your
way through that
um yeah it was amazing uh somewhere in
the middle of that third quarter
um
and man you just don't see this at Ohio
State there was that
that dread of
The Inevitable Defeat like oh no they're
doing it again to us and that just is
such a unusual spot that's what Ohio
state does to everybody else and
um I think a couple of those decisions
by Ryan day to not go for it on fourth
down Michigan had that eight minute
drive uh that bridge the third and
fourth quarter where they just did
whatever they wanted it was slow and
methodical and it wiped out the game uh
and then you just had the knockout
punches late by uh by Donovan Edwards
and um it was probably half empty by the
end of the game just if you if he had
given me that option I would have been
long odds but uh it was a tough day in
Columbus no question and it was only a
couple of years ago where Jim Harbaugh
was taking a pay cut just trying to hold
on for dear life now and now he's up for
Coach of the Year
yeah I don't want to encourage bosses
giving pay cuts but uh it was certainly
an effective manner uh on Harbaugh you
got a pay cut and he's uh 24 and 2 since
and uh it's probably going to playoff no
matter what happens this weekend but um
he uh this isn't easy to do to change a
program like that now he was winning and
and there was a sort of a belief of like
because he wasn't beating Ohio State and
twice they were really close games but
because he hadn't beaten Ohio State
there was sort of his belief like he's
failing he was getting compared to Scott
Frost at Nebraska they were winning nine
ten games a year they were doing well
they just weren't beating Ohio State but
what has happened in these last two
years the identity they found the buy-in
on this team
um you talk to these players it's
amazing how fired up they are about
Michigan and the team the team the team
I mean it is like Michigan uh you know
the fantasy uh text I mean they just
love it and Harbaugh has got the program
that he always wanted to build and he
came back to do this he came back to
settle family business for the
Wolverines and start beating Michigan
and Michigan State and win big tens
again and he's got that and now he says
Asian leaving after the the Vikings
didn't want him last year he could be
there for a while and it'll be
interesting to see what he goes from
here but he's got a heck of a team this
year uh I would still put George as the
favorite to win the national title but
it's a lot closer if those two match up
than it was uh uh a year ago and it was
like yeah I don't think this is going to
end uh end well
we got the 12 team playoff format and uh
got it uh fast passed here to uh 2024.
uh why was the Rose Bowl the uh the loan
holdout
you know it goes back to the Rose Bowl's
historic
uh
place in the sport and they had their
own contract with the college football
playoff and because of that they were
able all alone to veto expansion I've
been coming on the show a long time
talking about playoff expansion Dan I've
written a lot of Stories books nobody
ever believed when I would say yeah it's
getting held up because the Rose Bowl
wants to have the sunset at the end of
the third quarter of their game
and that's what's holding up a billion
dollar Enterprise and people go no no no
no no not possible
I I did not believe when I started
reporting on this I did not believe it
myself but you end up as one of the
obstacles it's like well can we have the
sun set at the start of the third
quarter no has to set over the same game
and it is I'll give it this it is one
heck of a sunset yeah it is it is one of
the great sunsets in America but this is
a billion dollar operation and if you're
the president of Mississippi State you
go I don't really care okay I want the
money and the president of Mississippi
State said get this thing done and he
was in charge and they finally got it
done so the Rose Bowl has given up all
the petty ridiculous disagreements the
infighting the politics I mean the stuff
that held this up is amazing and they
still they still can't kick the bowl
games they still can't kick them out
like it's amazing if we if you said to
Roger Goodell I think the AFC
Championship game should be owned and
operated by uh like the tourism Board of
San Antonio and you should play it there
every year not in Kansas City or fun
yeah and they get half the money
like no one would go for this but
small steps but this is a big step
they're going to be a real playoff next
year will be the last of the four team
and then um it's going to be really wild
after that what's the downside
I mean those of us that love college
football the most love college football
for its inefficiencies it's
ridiculousness it's the whole thing
right she will lose some Ohio we'll see
you don't even know if this is true but
there was a sense on Saturday at the
Horseshoe that Michigan had ended Ohio
State season for all effect uh next year
or if there's a 12 team playoff that is
not the case now you're getting better
seating you're gonna you should have
advantages of home field or a buy and
some different things but that's not the
same as as ending the sport but that
said those games are rare and quite
honestly we're not that I believe this
should happen but if USC loses on Friday
night Ohio State's back in anyway so did
it really end their season so those
magical moments where somebody ends the
season in that you know that one loss
but conversely
you know we're going to get so many
great games and and there's so much more
money there's so much more interest so
many more teams that'll be involved in
the season uh I mean we're going into a
weekend here this is the championship
game weekend none of the games May
matter by Friday night the whole weekend
could be over like it's a weird way to
run a sport where you're just like oh
yeah this doesn't matter
we're going to get to revenue sharing at
any point or is that just called a
different thing nil
with the players yeah
I think we're a ways from that
um I mean you watch how they're kicking
and screaming against nil but um and
it's a much bigger step if you make them
employees uh they don't want to do that
uh they were hoping for Congressional uh
you know input or whatever I don't know
how they thought the United States
Congress was going to solve their I mean
what this is how bad the business shape
it is with lack of leadership when
you're asking Congress to come run your
business I don't know too many
businesses Industries saying please help
us
um and not in subsidies but come up with
a rule I think I think we're down the
line I think with the nil it's much
fairer guys are making a lot of money
um those playoff games will be huge
Boons to players bottom line I happen to
be in I covered the game in Columbus I
happen to be in Ann Arbor on Sunday and
I went to the M Den their big store
right in downtown Ann Arbor and I
watched five people by Donovan Edwards
Jersey in 12 minutes right like there's
going to be a whole bunch of 10 year
olds wearing Donovan Edwards seven and
he's getting a cut of that now in the
past you know so you win those big games
there is a financial reward it feels
fairer all of that stuff I I don't know
that there is um I think we're a ways
away from from the true sharing of
Revenue
I wondered though and I don't know if
schools got around this that if I had
your jersey number
but not your name
on your jersey and you could buy it yeah
but they didn't get the player any money
yeah that's what I'm saying oh yeah they
put their number on there yeah but but
but nowadays even if they have they
don't put your name on the back because
not you can put your name on the back
and you can get a cut
but what if they don't have your name on
the back of that Jersey and you go into
the bookstore
well if I'm Donovan Edwards I'm going
down the A.D and saying put my name on
the background I'm transferring to Ohio
State 's here whoa come on
see me running 85 yards I'm getting a
cut I mean
no no school would do that because that
would be absolutely disastrous uh you
know so I mean there's even stuff you
know Pell Grants and the and the all the
different
um cost of living and stuff I mean you
have college football players making
clearing tax-free 40 45 000 at the top
level and going to school for free so
that's a you know that's a 60 000 70 65
000 okay is it is it equal to personal I
mean Patrick Mullins making what 50
million dollars but
um it's a big step in the right
direction and it's a different sport so
we'll see where that goes but I don't
see anything imminent about hey let's
let's share the revenue no one wants to
share the revenue and I don't know the
player is going to organize well enough
to do that if they created a union it'd
be very hard to get a strike they don't
really have much power on this
have we run out of Heisman candidates
I got I had a guy uh he I talked to him
after the Ohio State game they said
um
like who else is there
um you know Stroud's out Quorum didn't
play well so it's it's it was all about
USC better play they better play well
out there so I think it's a it's a
one-man race unless it's five picks on
Friday night
great to talk to you as always thank you
Dan
appreciate it Dan talk to you soon Dan
Wetzel Yahoo sports columnist podcast
host